now before the vaccine british
pandemic policy was marked by repeated
failures
but his vaccine rollout has become the
envy of many other countries especially
those across the channel kate andrews
joins us to bring us up to date with the
latest stats she's the editor of the
spectator's daily
covert 19 update newsletter uh the only
roundup you really need for the latest
on the coronavirus pandemic in britain
and abroad
kate over to you thanks andrew at
yesterday's press conference
chief medical officer chris woody said
that the uk was past its peak
of this wave of the virus and as you can
see from this first slide
the data really reflects that daily
cases are now hovering around where they
were in early december
when england was coming out of its first
lockdown and as spectator tv watchers
will remember from last week we looked
at hospitalization emissions
in the uk and those also appeared to be
on a downward trajectory but we were
cautious
knowing that these figures can be
revised upwards but it's a week later
and if we look at this next slide
we can see that decrease in emissions
very clearly now
still chris witty warned yesterday that
these figures were incredibly high in
his words
that the nhs was still at risk from
suffering capacity trouble
uh what he deemed as extraordinarily
fast in a bad circumstance
um i'm going to come back to that point
in just a minute what these decreases
could mean potentially for lockdown
easing but first i want to look at the
office
for national statistics antibody survey
as you can see on this next slide
the latest survey shows 15.3 antibody
prevalence in england that's up from
10.7
last month now back in the first wave an
increase
would suggest higher case numbers and
more circulation of the virus
this time around infections are
certainly playing their role again
especially with the more aggressive
strain the kent strain of the virus but
the exciting news is that vaccines are
also playing their part too now
as you can see from this next slide the
age breakdown
is really remarkable the highest
antibody positivity in england is for
the over 80s who of course have been
prioritized
for the vaccine roughly 25 of that age
group is now showing antibodies and
that's with a 95
confidence interval now this latest
survey runs 28 days
leading up to january 18th and we know
that it can take several weeks for
antibodies to kick in
once you've had the jab so this survey
is really looking at the beginning
stages
of the vaccine rollout which started on
the 8th of december it's accounting for
maybe up to a month but what's exciting
is that if we consider the fact that
what we're looking at here
is showing the beginning phases of the
rollout that was suggested in the next
survey
we could be seeing some extraordinary
figures that are taking into account the
millions of people
who have been getting their jabs and
building up antibodies
and the ons is going to be releasing
these surveys fortnightly now so we're
going to get to see
that vaccine factor play out soon
all of this bolsters the narrative that
the uk's procurement process
and rollout of the vaccine has been
right it's gotten its strategies
right a story which katie balls has
written up in the magazine this week and
i know is going to
be discussing in detail in a little bit
between the four nations as you can see
in this slide
we've reached the 10 million jab
milestone and the uk is still on track
to hit its mid-february target of the
first four priority groups
being vaccinated and there's now talk of
early april when the over 50s
that's uh priority groups one through
nine would be
vaccinated so what does this all mean
for the easing of lockdown
well on the one hand you had even more
good news this week the
pre-print of an oxford trial published
in the landsat
which showed that the vaccine had a 76
efficacy rate that's six percentage
points higher
than was originally thought and
crucially that it seemed to cut
transmissions by
two-thirds now this last slide shows
some sage modeling which projected that
vaccines cutting transmissions by over
50
percent could get deaths to near zero
around april
though hospitalizations might trail this
as under 65s make up
roughly 65 of those in the icu right now
of course they are more likely
to recover but there's a catch in this
slide it's also assuming september style
restrictions
that means major social distancing rules
still in place
that's certainly not what we would call
normal
so as we hit these targets mid-february
the most vulnerable being inoculated
hopefully by early april the over 50s
being inoculated
pressure is going to mount on
politicians for society to start opening
up and there are major questions
to be answered how low do
hospitalization and death rates have to
be in order for us to meaningfully
reopen and what is the tolerance for
risk
health secretary matt hancock told the
spectator just last month
that once the most vulnerable were
protected that we were going to cry
freedom but whether the government is
actually willing to make the case for
freedom
is a different story indeed back to you
andrew
uh just before you go kate um there's
been a lot of argument mainly from the
french about the
oxford vaccine and also some reports
that you could get vaccinated with say
pfizer for the first dose but a
different vaccine for the second just
tell us a bit more about that
sure those are two separate stories the
first is that there have been criticisms
from european leaders about the oxford
astrosenica vaccine
this is very strange given that the
european medicines agency has approved
the vaccine for all age groups but there
are still some leaders
suggesting that we don't know enough
about it to say whether or not it would
protect
the most vulnerable i.e those in older
age groups the good news from that
pre-print oxford trial that we got this
week
is that the efficacy rate is thought
actually to be higher than we
originally estimated it to be all the
signs are still
pointing in a positive direction for the
oxford vaccine
and i think what you could take away as
well is that the the eu's um
a desire to get more oxford jabs into
the block in their push to get a higher
order it's going to be slightly
undermined by
major european leaders including
emmanuel macron suggesting they're not
going to use it to inoculate their most
vulnerable why wouldn't you then
keep those jabs in the uk where we are
using it to inoculate
the elderly the second thing you
mentioned andrew is
a voluntary trial in which they're going
to look at what is essentially a vaccine
cocktail if you
give somebody one type of jab first and
another type of jab second to see if you
can
increase its effectiveness this is all
going to be voluntary
volunteers are going to know that
they're they're part of this trial it is
not going to be carried out as part of
the
major vaccine rollout to make sure
everyone's inoculated
so nobody needs to worry that that trial
is being conducted on them when they get
their vaccine
everybody will know going into it that
they're in that trial and it's exciting
really it could be a real discovery
process
if we find out that mixing these
vaccines together can get a higher
efficacy rate
it means people are better protected
okay the only unhappy person will be
president macron
uh but we don't really bother too much
about that
you